and maybe you can help us answer some of
these questions how's that this is the
closest we can come right now to
somewhat of a debate in the 20 years of
research and more than 40,000 hours of
my time for zero forty thousand hours of
my time and so that's where this
conversation gets so contentious because
it's multi-generational indoctrination
in a belief in a manufactured product
and so when you challenge that belief
system you know what caught immediately
what people have is cognitive dissonance
it's like wait wait that's not right I
know this to be true really do you know
this to be child what if we know that
there's foreign proteins there's cow
blood there's gelatin all of the gelatin
is porcine based pig base and we we're
told that saving one innocent life is as
you save the world you know you eat so
beautiful yeah that's anomaly Combe
greetings of peace
welcome to the Dean show subscribe if
you haven't already my next guest has
been diving deep into the science of
this issue for over 40 with over 40,000
hours twenty plus years and we are going
to have a semi debate a reaction to this
video and we invite any specialists in
this area who would like to come on who
is qualified to come on in our next
hopefully meeting with the doctor to
have a debate over this a talk over this
so we can god-willing get to the truth
on this matter
dr. Shari Tenpenny how are you good good
thank God good and thank you for being
on the Dean show with us you're welcome
so tell us what makes you qualified to
talk about a topic like this lots of
years of study you know I I'm a
board-certified physician so in my first
career I was a board-certified emergency
medicine physician and the director of a
level 2 trauma center for 12 years I
moved to Cleveland in 1996 to start a
practice up here and then in September
of 2000 I went to the National Vaccine
Information Center meeting in Washington
DC and I came home and said how did I
miss this topic I mean I grew up in a
chiropractic family where we my
grandfather my father three uncles and
two cousins was a chiropractor and I
wasn't vaccinated as a child none of my
cousin's I don't think any of my cousins
were either and we all had what I would
call age-appropriate measles mumps
rubella chickenpox and all of those
things so when I came home from that
meeting and after four days of listening
to scientists and researchers and
lawyers and parents of vaccine injured
kids I thought you know maybe I ought to
start to look into this
well that looking into this has turned
into 20 years of research and more than
40,000 hours of my time for zero forty
thousand hours of my time over the last
twenty years exploring problems
associated with vaccination and the only
things that I have actually looked at
and studied from where peer-reviewed
medical literature that is accepted by
mainstream medicine and the CDC
documents the Center for Disease Control
and I H FDA you know all of those things
and so with all of those years of study
and being a being a physician I can
strongly and firmly stand that vaccines
are not safe they don't keep you from
getting sick and they definitely can
cause harm well hold on I mean this is
we're trying to ascertain the truth
we're trying to get to the truth here
that's where we're having you on the
program we try to get other people also
on to kind of have a dialogue a debate
it seems like it's very difficult to get
someone to kind to come up from the side
that is really advocating safe and
effective safe and effective so to hear
their side to put you guys together are
you willing to do something like that
have you done something like that we
tried to look to see if there was any
debates because sometimes you got to
just go back and forth and let the
person does that decide let the person
look at both sides but we don't see much
it is happening why is that we've tried
multiple times on multiple occasions
over the years to to set up a really
well-structured well-designed debate the
most recent one that I participated in
was in Atlanta it would have been
probably November of 2018
it was probably in that in that
timeframe and we we chose Atlanta we
were outside of the CDC we've got people
from Emory there was five people that
were scientists and researchers and very
Pro vet vaccine advocates on the one
side and then there was me and a hand
you know six or seven other people on
the other side it was going to be a very
well controlled debate everybody got the
questions and a dance there wasn't gonna
be any gotcha you know they got in the
you could prepare a statement we had a
professional moderator that was gonna
you know say that you know give each
people each person adequate amounts of
time it was gonna be recorded we were
gonna have live studio audience that
could come up and ask questions very
well-structured very high level so nope
nope everybody would feel here would
feel heard two days before we were
actually going to have this seminar this
was in I said outside of Atlanta the
pro-vaccine people refused to show up
and mass all five of them said they
wouldn't come because if they engaged in
a debate that that would give credence
to the fact that there was something
worthy of debate and as far as they were
concerned the science was done they we
were wrong they were right we there was
nothing worthy of debate and several
others there have been several other
opportunities like that that have been
set up just in the last year or two and
at the last minute they all bagged they
won't they won't come to the table which
to me speaks volumes because if they are
so right and so sure that they are so
wouldn't you love to have an opportunity
to take dr. Shari Tenpenny on a public
stage in front of everybody and put a
heel of your boot to her neck and bury
her once and for all but instead they
say no we're not going to do the debate
now there was a debate that was happened
I think it was about 2009 I was in Texas
and as myself and Don Richardson who is
part of the NVIC advocacy forum and
there was a public health official
actually did come to the table to have a
debate it was very similar in structure
we had you know everybody had their
questions ahead of time there was a
moderator and before we were going up on
the stage it was maybe three four
hundred people in the auditorium we were
kind of just mulling around and talking
and I believe this gentleman's name was
dr. Betts and I went over and I shook
his hand and I thanked him for coming
and I thought this is a great
opportunity for people to hear both
sides and then they could decide and
they could ask legitimate questions and
I said you know most pieces yeah he said
I drew the short straw and I said what
does that mean he said well most people
refuse to do this I said why is that he
goes it never goes well for us he said
that he said that but why if you have
the truth it should go easy for you I
don't understand because they don't the
only thing that the science is really on
our side you know if there's any doubt
there's if there's any doubt that
vaccines are causing harm in my opinion
there's no doubt that we should stop and
have a complete moratorium on it until
we figure it out if we've got thousands
and tens of thousands of children and
adults being harmed every single year by
vaccines then we need to take a step
back and decide what are we doing and
why I mean if the only thing that we're
doing is vaccinating to avoid a fever a
cough a rash and some diarrhea which is
what the vast majority of these
childhood infections are then we need to
take a step back the only thing they
have left on their side is character
assassination name-calling and
mudslinging and calling us names tinfoil
hat anti science anti-vaxxers and you
guys don't know what you're talking
about when in fact we really do I I'm
not an anti-vaxxer I'm not into
conspiracy theories I just want the
truth
and if someone was going to put
something if there was some controversy
about a certain substance you're gonna
put in your car engine
and it can possibly ruin the engine you
would investigate it more but this is a
really these are our children these are
children I just I want to be
well-informed and the doctors they take
a Hippocratic oath you know do no harm
informed consent so I want to be
informed thoroughly and I want the
audience to be inform you make your own
decision especially now that now there's
this talk about forcing even adults and
making it mandatory
we know that penicillin if somebody had
an infection and you couldn't force
someone would you as a doctor for
someone to have to have to take
penicillin if they had an infection I
mean penicillin is okay I mean but can
you force everyone to eat a certain food
or to take penicillin no and here's the
thing there's a follow-up to that if you
got a shot of penicillin and you had a
bad reaction you had a bad rash or you
had anaphylactic shock or you had some
sort of bad bad reaction to it you would
wear a MedicAlert bracelet the rest of
your life that says that you are
definitely allergic to to penicillin and
you should never take penicillin or any
of its forms ever again it's not true
with vaccines if you have any one of the
vaccines and children now get multiple
doses of 16 or 17 vaccines depending on
how you count them multiple doses of
that many vaccines and if any one of
them caused a serious reaction
anaphylactic shock seizure disorders
severe eczema all kinds there's a long
list of side effects and potential
complications instead of saying well
that you should not only not have that
vaccine again you should probably not
have any other vaccines that have
similar ingredients to that again
because we're not sure which ingredient
in that vaccine caused you to have that
bad reaction but instead they say and
nothing to do with the vaccine you need
a second dose of that it's the only area
of medicine where we don't take family
history into consideration you know you
go to the doctor and let's say you've
got headaches they will say did you have
a family history of headaches did your
mother have headaches did your
grandmother have migraines if you have a
history of key if you end up to have
cancer they want to know what your
family history is of cancer of heart
disease high blood pressure diabetes all
of those things are taken into
consideration when you
go to the doctor and talk about what's
wrong with you what about your family
history and in with vaccines it doesn't
matter if you had a both of the parents
had severe reactions to vaccines doesn't
matter if you had a sibling that maybe
even died from a vaccine reaction and
maybe even went so far into got injury
compensation from the government for
their serious reaction to a vaccine
doesn't matter you still have to get
your kids vaccinated so I want to be
well-informed I want the audience to be
well informed I want to make sure what
I'm putting in my body my children's
body my that it's safe it's actually
safe so I have a ton of questions and
the closest that now we can come to an
actual debate is what we'll do next and
and and the door is open I'm sure
tomorrow if we can get someone on you'd
be willing to come back on to have a
debate would you dr. sherry absolutely
okay absolutely it's there's there's
there's some very key points that they
avoid and if you could do that
I'd be happy to come and debate somebody
we have I actually had a friend of mine
in New Jersey who actually was willing
to put up $100,000 for a debate and
nobody would nobody would do under
$1,000 those yes Wow and that was with
him I'm it was that was it within this
calendar year that was in 2020 you know
since the first of the year he
challenged he had several people who are
like you know disparaging the on lines
and trolls that attack me all the time
which they do so he went out to them and
he said in some of them were physicians
he said listen Wow if you come and do
this I'll put up $100,000 to to to house
this debate and we'll pay you will pay
dr. Tenpenny will do this nobody would
do it mm-hmm
maybe we can get some bran I'm gonna say
a word and in our conversation you might
hear some terminologies I'm we're gonna
learn a lot from you and then maybe we
can share some things with you there's
some certain key words I like to define
I'm gonna say a word because in the
medical institution there are a lot of
Muslims now Muslims we're not terrorists
you know the myself yeah and Muslim is
simply one who has consciously chosen to
submit his or her will to the creator of
the heavens and earth to one God just
like Jesus Moses Abraham and all the
messengers that's that's what I Muslim
is a Muslim doesn't wish to harm an
animal let alone a human being but I
just make that clear dr. Shari time
because there's a lot of we see how the
media you know divides us and spreads
fear and all this stuff so there are a
lot the reason I mentioned this dr.
sherry ten pennies because there's a lot
of Muslim doctors out there a big
percentage so maybe we can get one of
them because they're supposed to you
know the people who are God conscious
who love God they should be advocate
advocates of truth and they shouldn't
fear you know anyone but God and and
we're we we're told that saving one
innocent life is as you saved the world
you know you meet so beautiful yeah
that's in the Quran so I'm gonna this is
the closest doctor Tenpenny that we can
come I'm gonna there's a doctor out
there who's a strong advocate to this
and we're gonna play his video and then
we can go maybe point by point and you
can help us now
because these are some of the points
that are common and maybe you can help
us answer some of these questions how's
that this is the closest we can come
right now to somewhat of a debate can we
do that okay
listening to the media you can really
lose your mind try to figure out what
the real deal about vaccines is because
there's so many contradictory points you
hear people screen with all these things
you don't know what to believe and I
empathize with the person who doesn't
have a great medical education to
understand what's true and what's not
we're venturing out in York City and
we're gonna ask people what they think
or what they believe or what they know
about vaccines to put it simply a
vaccine is the introduction of a virus
or part of a virus that allows your body
to see it to get used to it to build up
its defense and be protected if the real
thing does come along stop there okay so
this is what most physicians believe
that have never even bothered to read a
package insert and it's certainly what
parents know a whole lot more about than
they do from their doctors is that we've
been taught to believe that the only
thing that's coming through that needle
is a weakened or attenuated virus or a
piece of the the of the outside of the
bacteria a little piece of bacteria and
a little sterile water and so the virus
has been weakened they call that
attenuated and that we're just all we're
injecting into people is a little PSA
and attenuated or weakened virus are a
little part of a bacteria that's going
in to develop an ant
so in his words when the real thing
comes along you'll be protected the one
thing he's not addressed is all of these
there are more than there are more than
200 different chemicals that are used in
the manufacturing process of vaccines
now that that's spread out over the
various over the various dosages of
vaccines so it's not like you get one
shot with 200 chemicals in it but if you
get all all the doses of 17 different
vaccines you're going to get doses of
these chemicals many as several of them
are known carcinogens bait appropriate
lactone polysorbate 80 there's there's
still mercury in the vaccines I'll talk
a little bit more when he gets over into
the Illumina part about the stuff with
the aluminum but there are there are two
phenoxyethanol there's formaldehyde
there are like I said more than 200
different chemicals that are found in
vaccines and so if you just think that
the only thing you're doing is injecting
a little dead virus and a little sterile
water you got your science wrong and
although none of those VAX none of those
ingredients in any one individual vial
have ever been tested for synergistic
toxicity because sometimes when you put
two or three chemicals together the
toxic load ends up to be higher or more
burdensome on the recipient of that
vaccine than if you were just giving
each one of those chemicals individually
so not only is has there been no
synergistic toxicity within that one
vial both children get anywhere from
three to six sometimes seven vaccines on
a vaccination day when they go to the
doctor so there's no synergistic
toxicity in each one of those and
there's no synergistic toxicity in each
one of the other individual vials that
are going to be injected into your child
we know that there's foreign proteins
there's cow blood there's gelatin all of
the gelatin is porcine based Pig based
that's going into vaccines that are
being injected into children so his
whole thing of saying oh it's just a
little virus that's going in and that's
all we're doing is we're prepping the
immune system if I developed what they
call a protective antibody well here's
the thing about the protective antibody
is you can have very high levels of what
they call a protective antibody and
still contract the infection including
tetanus so that whole premise is just
the theory
on how vaccination works which isn't
even correct so you're saying it's just
a theory but the theory if it was
actually how that he painted it to be is
it seems like a good theory if it was
like that well yes and no I mean there's
two arms of the immune system there's
they call those two arms one arm is
called th one and the other arm is
called th too so there's two branches of
the immune system the th one immune
system is your white blood cells your
lymphocytes and something called
toll-like receptors tol L - Li ke
toll-like receptors those receptors are
on the surface of all of your cells and
they are hyper-vigilant I mean what
they're doing is they're monitoring your
internal Malu all day long and
separating the bacteria and the viruses
that are all inside of us we know
there's several trillion viruses and
bacteria that we carry around just
normally as part of our normal
microbiome in our gut on our skin in our
mouth in our brain all of those normal
good bacteria and viruses that we have
so the toll-like receptors are vigilant
they and they they look around and say
is there any pathogen that's in here
that doesn't belong here that's not part
of the normal and the normal crowd in
the neighborhood and if they find a
virus or a bacteria that gets into your
bloodstream which it does all day long
it does it from brushing our teeth from
having a bowel movement from getting a
cut on your skin from having sex from
all of those things you get bacteria
into your bloodstream and these
toll-like receptors notice that there's
something here that doesn't belong and
they send out some little messenger
molecules called cytokines and they tell
the white blood cells the macrophages
hey see that one over there
get rid of that that doesn't belong here
so all day long by a process called
pattern recognition our god-given
internal immune system our primary
immune system is keeping us well and
healthy from all of the bacteria in our
environment that end up in our
bloodstream those toll-like receptors
were not even developed we're not even
discovered until the the early
two-thousands and the two people who
worked in them and found toll-like
receptor 4 which was the first one
they've now identified ten but toll-like
receptor 4 they were given the Nobel
prai's of internal medicine in 2011
which means this is relatively new
science which should up end the vaccine
industry because all day long this is
taking care of us if you actually get a
real infection so you get let's say the
flu so you get the so an influenza virus
gets into your system or in it's either
much more virulent or you get a lot of
them in at the same time that kind of
overwhelms that th one pathway the first
thing that the th one pathway does is
turns up the temperature they start to
create a fever because they know that
the fever will kill off those invaders
so as the fever goes up there's the
cytokine thing that develops these
messenger molecules that are talking
back and forth between all of your white
blood cells and your toll-like receptors
and the various parts of your internal
immune system that kills off those
invaders towards the end of your
infection after we've had the th one and
the th two pathways dancing together and
the in the presence of fever have killed
off the virus or bacteria that came in
and caused you to get sick at the very
end of that there's something called
b-cells B as in boy b-cells that come
along and glob onto this entire process
and then they make an antibody that says
I remember this infection so that the
next time that this shows up I know to
glob onto it and neutralize it
the beast' the antibodies that are made
in the presence of fever and a real
infection have different different
characteristics than the fake antibody
that's made from a vaccine and so then
and the b-cells the antibodies are late
to the game they're the last thing to
show up when you're when you're
recovering from an infection so by
injecting foreign matter which is
viruses bacteria and cow blood and
chicken parts and in cells from dog
kidneys and and all of those different
chemicals and mercury and aluminum
injecting foreign matter and the
children to create an antibody that
doesn't even keep you from getting sick
when those invaders really come in means
that this young gentleman this young
doctor really doesn't understand
immunology or have any have any
understanding of what was really going
on in the body in the presence of in
presence of an infection
before we continue the video just two
points so carcinogen means that what
that this can cause cancer so these
ingredients can cause cancer parsonage
every every chemical in the environment
and every chemical that's used in
medicine every chemical that's used in
your car every chemicals that's used to
clean your house all of those chemicals
are made the EPA requires those
chemicals to have something called an
MDS MSDS sheet material safety data
sheet MSDS sheet which lists all the
properties of that chemical and if it
can cause cancer what happens if you
breathe it in if you splash it in your
eyes if you get it on your skin it tells
you all the safety things that happen
that's an OSHA requirement and it's also
regulated by the EPA so every one of
those chemicals inside of those vaccines
have an MSDS sheet so they we can we can
research them and understand if you were
just exposed to that if single chemical
all by itself here's the potential
problems that it can cause now when it's
mixed together with seven or several
different chemicals and inject it into
the body they don't they've never really
studied it when you read a package
insert it will say that this vaccine has
never been tested for carcinogenicity
meaning it's never been tested to see if
it causes cancer it's never never been
tested for teratogenicity meaning it's
never been tested to see if it causes
birth defects it's never been tested for
mutagenicity means it disrupts your
genes and causes all kinds of other
types of health problems and it's never
been tested see if it causes infertility
there is so everyth there's every single
vaccine that's on the market and there's
about 67 that have been approved for use
in the United States now some of those
are for only for adults some of them are
for military some of them are for travel
but there are 17 vaccines that have been
approved for children of those 17
vaccines if you pull the package insert
you will see a paragraph on every single
one of them that says we've it's not
been tested for its ability to cause
cancer birth defects infertility or
messing up your genes I will continue
with the video and the closest that we
can come to a debate just couple more
points when you say there's never been
thing also on a synergetic effect like
can we make the analogy like what
happens if you take people know like if
your car dies you get the jumper cables
and you got red and black so if it we
know what happens if you put those two
together if you put red and black
together there's an explosion so just
have that in your mind
so if you do a synergetic a test to see
there's never been like if you put this
toxic chemical with this one or you put
this this shot with this one there's
never been testing on that nope are you
sure in vivo in human beings there have
not been they don't even develop they
don't even do testing to see if we've
developed antibodies to any of the
foreign proteins that get injected we
know that of all the vaccines that have
cow blood in them that's a foreign
protein there are at least eighteen
hundred different types of foreign
proteins in each Beck's batch of fetal
bovine serum and they're up to four
thousand active ingredients and each
batch varies because each fetus that
they take the blood from and then is
used in the manufacture of vaccine
varies based on the health of the mother
with the mother 8 and how old the baby
was when they actually harvested its
blood to be put into the vaccines so
there's no even we don't even know if
we've developed antibodies to those we
don't know if we've developed antibodies
to the foreign proteins of the aborted
fetal cells that are in vaccines we
don't know we haven't tested any of that
wait a bit yeah sorry I'm sure you're
sure because you have to be sure I mean
you put your neck out online you know
you've gotten against gone against all
odds you put in forty thousand hours of
research you're a board-certified
medical doctor is that that's correct
and you've been doing this for over 20
years and you people are just waiting
for you to make a mistake so they can
call you out so you really have to know
the science yep that's true so tell me
dr. Tenpenny before we go to the next
part of the video you mentioned pork as
Muslims we don't there's just a few
things that we stay away from along with
just following the you know the laws of
the Creator being upright being a
righteous human being being morally
upright and then the dietary code we
stay away from alcohol no alcohol we
don't drink
and also pork pork is a big one you
mentioned pork in the the pig look what
tell us more a little bit about what
does that actually mean when there's pig
DNA and whatnot in this they found that
the pig DNA is a little bit different
topic they did find traces of porcine
DNA in the road and one of the rotavirus
vaccines one of the rotavirus vaccines
are is an oral drop I don't remember
which one it was but if it was rota tech
or rota rota VAX but it was an oral drop
that had they found traces of pig DNA in
there and that's an oral drop that they
give to stop kids from having diarrhea
which we don't even need that vaccine at
all in the United States you know at all
because the reason that they do that is
because kids can get rotavirus
infections which can give them profound
diarrhea and it's more important in
maybe third world countries because they
may not have access to first world care
like hospitalizations or IV fluids or
even things like Pedialyte for oral you
know clean water for for oral
rehydration but they did find pick pig
DNA in those in that vaccine but more
broadly they use some a product called
gelatin and gelatin comes from the
hooves of the pigs and the in in all
gelatin today they used to use some
bovine gelatin they don't anymore and I
just looked this up last night on the
FDA website to just confirm that that
was true that they only use pork gelatin
in vaccines the pork gelatin is in the
chickenpox vaccine it's in the MMR
vaccine and it's in the it's I made it I
have a chart that you I can actually
send you so you can actually see it it's
actually and it's also in the shingles
vaccine for adults and it's in very
large quantities I mean the the MMR
vaccine has fourteen thousand five
hundred micrograms which is a big dose
the chickenpox vaccine is over twelve
thousand micrograms and the largest dose
a pork gelatin is in the shingles
vaccine which is targeted towards adults
yeah okay let's continue on with the
video what do you think about
vaccinations
I don't even though
that and one of the reasons why people
is why this conversation gets so hostile
is that vaccines have become a religion
it's a belief system I believe in
vaccines it's a it's a religion it's a
it's a friend of mine Robert Scott Bell
that has a radio program he always
always calls it genuflecting at the knee
at the at the altar of medical mysticism
we believe this is going to do something
for us I mean we don't say we believe in
light bulbs we don't say we believe in
cars their products their products and
vaccines aren't a medical product but
yet that's the language we believe in it
and so if we have this
multi-generational faith and belief in a
manufactured pharmaceutical product that
causes great harm and you believe that
it's the right thing to do and someone
comes along and says well wait a minute
maybe there's another sides of this
story it's like if someone came along to
you with your religion and your faith
and said wait a minute maybe that's not
true let's tell you there's another side
of the story you know the first thing
that you do is you say wait a minute
this is I believe this I know this to be
true do you really believe that it's
true when are we talking about vaccines
there's another side of his story
because it's a product it's a it's a
manufactured product just like a car or
a bicycle or a light bulb or a couch
it's a product that we have faith and
belief in and so that's where this
conversation gets so contentious because
it's multi-generational indoctrination
in a belief in a manufactured product
and so when you challenge that belief
system you know what caught immediately
what people have is cognitive dissonance
it's like wait wait that's not right I
know this to be true really do you know
this to be true what if there's another
side to this vaccine story that's so
when she says when he says oh you don't
believe in vaccines well maybe we should
talk about what the chemicals are maybe
we should talk about what's coming
through that needle maybe we should talk
about the people who get harmed and
killed from these vaccines because it's
a product okay we'll continue I think
there were like experiments
and they put the you know the virus in
us so did your doctor try and like push
you or convince you to do him yeah like
always they always do that what why do
you think they do that they get
painfully stopped when I started doing
this in researching this the vaccine
industry now think about the vaccine
industry as a pie diagram and eat
there's a slice for cancer drugs there's
a slice for blood pressure drugs there's
a slice for diabetes drugs there's a
slice for vaccines and the production of
vaccines when I started doing this 20
years ago that slice in of the vaccine
industry was about 10 billion with a B
dollars 20 years ago it's now over sixty
two billion dollars and with the
addition of the very high dollar
vaccines like Gardasil they're pushing
it up to saying over the next ten years
that pie diagram will have a value of
over a hundred billion dollars now if
any if let's say that you know I'll be
generous and say that vaccines only
cause damage and half the people that
get them I actually think it's every
person can be damaged by every any of
the vaccines but let's say that 50% of
people get when they when they get a
vaccine they get at the side-effect that
develops is asthma allergies eczema ad D
ADHD the neurological conditions
autoimmune diseases then when they get
sick the first thing they do is they go
to the doctor and and the doctor never
says have you had a vaccine that has
these ingredients in it that are known
to cause these side effects because
doctors believe that vaccines are safe
protective and harmless so what happens
is they go to the doctor they get a
bunch of tests when those tests are
negative they are inconclusive they send
them to the specialist who runs more
tests and then they sent them to the
super specialist that runs more tests
and they try to come up with a diagnosis
they never say well probably it was that
vaccine that you got just like that shot
of penicillin that you may have gotten
that caused the problem they never put
those two things together because that
disrupts the paradigm so all that money
for all those doctors all those tests
all those follow-up visits to come to
the conclusion where you have a
diagnosis of say lupus or erysipelas or
some sort of
of a neurological problem you've got
seizure disorders now you've become a
customer for life for the pharmaceutical
industry that you have to buy a
medication or your insurance has to pay
for a medication just does it manage
your condition for the rest of your life
so to say that there's no money in it
the doctor doctors get lots of money for
paying for and for giving the shots and
administering the stock shots and they
have zero liability if there's any for
any adverse event that happens none they
are completely protected by the
government if your child gets a vaccine
and dies there's no recourse for that to
that doctor the hospital or the clinic
doctors gets paid for counseling doctors
get paid for administering the shot
doctors get paid for each one of the
individual vaccines that they give they
actually have training programs for
doctors to teach doctors how to
appropriately document all of that in
their charts so that they can get paid
by the insurance companies so for him to
say there's nothing in it for doctors as
a flat-out lie for him to say there's
nothing in it for the pharmaceutical
industry is another flat-out lie that
should be stamped across the video you
know they're that fact check now like
Facebook in them they had the fat check
and they should maybe think about
removing his video because fact-checking
it put that back check up there for sure
okay let's continue on vaccines are not
a blockbuster hit for doctors or
pharmaceutical companies most of the
money that's dedicated to this research
goes to universities stop there is not
that is not true that is not true that
the money that comes from vaccines goes
to it goes to resit universities our tax
dollars pay for the Rd for the vaccine
industry at the NIH and at various
universities our tax dollars give them
grants to develop a vaccine and if the
vaccine or a drug gets to the point
where it looks promising and it has
commercial potential we then hand it
over we don't sell it we hand it over to
the via to the to the pharmaceutical
industry for them to continue
researching it and to commercialize it
they get a 22 year patent on it that
they becomes a blockbuster vaccine or
drug that they make billions and
billions of dollars off of it now I was
actually at a meeting
where I actually actually heard this
presentation and I said to I said to the
presenters who were from the NIH I said
well it seems as though it would make
sense to me if that product or that
vaccine does become commercially viable
and the VAX in the pharmaceutical
industry is going to take it forward for
the next 22 years and make billions of
dollars off of it you know they should
look back at the R&D dollars that took
it to that point that came from the
taxpayer and let's say it was ten
billion dollars that was the the R&D
that came up to that it seems as though
it would make sense for the
pharmaceutical industry to put that
money back into that pot so it could be
recycled you know they're gonna have 22
years of revenues it seems as though
they should pay back for the R&D you
know what their answer was to me huh
we've never nobody's ever said that
before but I guess that would be a
pretty good idea we pay and pay and pay
and pay for these drugs and vaccines as
consumers over and over and over again
I'll continue on
it's his heart wrenching as it gets
autism and children well the vast
majority of medical experts insist that
vaccines are generally safe you're going
to stand on the stage and say that
vaccines and autism are unrelated and is
the most bogus I've seen the
correlations between multiple vaccines
at a very young age
and autism and other problems that
people have people think autism or
whatever is a risk right yeah okay I
tell you like a little history about how
it's really interesting so 1998 okay
stop because we can blow through this
whole little thing that he said here
first of all in 1998 dr. Ian D Wakefield
did a paper and if he'd actually read
the paper he would know what it said and
what the paper actually said was that
that he had children who are autistic
who also had bowel disease and their
parents came to him and begged him as a
gastroenterologist to do a colonoscopy
on these children he did a colonoscopy
on 12 children and found that they had a
condition called ileal lymphoid
hyperplasia
which is a mouthful and when you boil
that down what that means is they had
swollen lymph nodes inside of their
intestinal tract all inflamed and when
they did a biopsy they found what they
thought was what appeared to be vaccine
strain measles that were causing the
inflammation the conclusion of that
paper which is more than 20 years old
said it appears as though vaccine strain
strange measles may be affecting the
guts of these children further research
is necessary there was no claim about
autism there was no claim connecting it
to autism there was nobody that said
vaccines cause autism that was
mainstream medical media propaganda and
slaying of dr. Andy Wakefield to say
they even have a verb of it now call it
Wakefield 'add so that they tried to
make a huge example of dr. Wakefield so
that no other physicians would dare to
speak up that's what that whole thing
was about and so since that time and so
when people that go oh well you know
this doctor from 1998 well let me tell
you something it was 22 years ago do you
think there's more research that may
have come out since then that shows
there is a connection between vaccines
and autism and every single package
insert talks about encephalitis which is
inflammation of the brain and
encephalopathy disrupting your brain so
it doesn't function and isn't that what
autism is so vaccines can cause
encephalitis encephalopathy but if you
say autism oh no absolutely not it
doesn't cause it and
we have a collection of more than 160
articles from peer-reviewed literature
showing vaccines causing encephalitis
and encephalopathy so by definition
vaccines are connected to autism and all
he said was again what what did he say
in the paper if they go people who
actually read it people go and actually
read what the conclusion of the paper
was it appears as though vaccine strain
measles may cause inflammation in the
gut more research is necessary okay so
it was just more research as necessary
exactly that's a good thing that we need
more research we need more research yeah
okay let's continue on in 1998 this guy
he was a doctor at the time his name is
dr. Wakefield he and II did not get a
huge and what he said about him getting
like a half a million dollars to vet
further this vaccine that isn't true
either
he does he's parroting the propaganda
rather than doing his own research and
knowing what the heck he's talking about
he did this study on 12 kids not a
thousand kids not a million kids 12
found that there was an increased risk
of getting autism the paper if they got
vaccine this specific vaccine MMR
vaccine measles mumps and rubella and
can cause autism too and this is the
only one they focused on his MMR you can
get brain encephalitis and
encephalopathy from TPT from hepatitis A
from hepatitis B from any of the
vaccines in fact the 1986 vaccine injury
compensation Act was passed because the
pharmaceutical company was getting sued
to Kingdom Come by all of the brain
damage being caused by the pertussis
vaccines so this whole little diatribe
about a 22 year old paper of about the
MMR vaccine he really really has not
investigated this at all he really
hasn't he was paid five hundred thousand
dollars to try and create this link so
another one fact check he's busted not
because of a law company that wanted to
make lawsuits right and this is only 12
kids he tested so now
like thousands or hundred thousand he
tested them to see what was wrong with
their gut because these kids that have
severe autism have horrible belly pain
and they sit and they rock and they cry
and they rock and they cry and they have
horrible constipation they may not have
a bowel movement for three weeks and so
these parents were wanting to know what
was going on with their in their guts
and it's again a 22 year old paper and
this is your only defense against
vaccines don't cause autism and I can't
which is deltrese group actually sued
the CDC and one and one in court because
of the CDC claiming that vaccines do not
cause autism and having it on their
website so they sued and said okay prove
it
show us your documented science show us
your research that proves that vaccines
don't cause do not cause autism because
we got a body of evidence over here that
it that makes the link show us what your
sense researches through multiple FOIA
requests that resulted in a lawsuit they
at the CDC only came up with two studies
that were weak at best that showed that
there was no potential connection
between vaccines and autism so they've
lost on every front on that argument
they actually got sued by this
independent group of researchers and
well lawyer independently you know it's
Dell big trees group which is which is
from hi fire and his foundation and his
business is called I can and so as I can
decide is his is his business and they
actually sued the CDC for evidence to
prove that vaccines don't cause autism
and what they came up with was weak at
best so that they wanted evidence they
wanted them to produce this evidence so
it short oh we're happy to be wrong
happy to sit down and shut up and go
away they really came up with nothing
and people can look this up this is this
is they can check this out there you can
find it you can find the lawsuit and
everything and he found that there was
an increased risk and it was published
they took away his medical license there
was a really big deal about I cannot say
this more clearly
there has been no association between
autism and vaccination zero none so that
one what does statement he just said
that's another it's just wrong there is
a a paper that I can provide to you that
has a hundred and fifty I think it's a
hundred up to one hundred fifty seven it
may be even more than that now it's a
collection of vaccines that cause
encephalitis encephalopathy which is
autism right and so if you spent you say
an autism oh you're a pariah you're a
conspiracy theorist you wear tinfoil hat
but if you say encephalitis
encephalopathy which is the same thing
oh well that's just a medical
terminology zero none if you had to
convince someone that told you that
despite like the best research that
you've seen that there's no link to
autism that they still believe that
there's a correlation somehow I would
suggest to them that having a child with
autism is a lot better than having a
dead child stop obviously she's never
been around autistic severely autistic
children who are teens and 20 year olds
still in diapers that can't feed
themselves that take the stool out of
their of their diaper and smear it on
walls and sitter camps can't talk can't
communicate sit all day long banging
their heads on the floors and have to
wear helmets
she's never been around that now yes a
dead child is really bad but they're
talking about measles the death rate
from measles was was 1 to 2 per 2
million in 1963 before they even
developed a measles vaccine so to roll
that forward into into 20 or 20 20 20 20
or 20 19 and say Omi's was deadly again
wrong
fact-check dead wrong I saw a
interesting clip from the Brady Bunch
a long time ago measles in the episode
first broadcast in 1969 all six of the
Brady kids come down with the measles
and it's no big deal
a slight temperature a lot of dots and a
great big smile a great big smile no
school for a few days if you have to get
sick she can't beat the measles and they
had the measles that hit the Brady Bunch
the whole family and then
they were just like you know okay you
know they weren't panicking there was no
fear amongst the house they're like okay
we'll call the doctor and then they just
pretty much you know we're at home state
laughing joking and they went on with
business why is it become another clip
it was from father knows best again from
the 1960s that his son was supposed to I
believe believe us either play
basketball or football and he went to
the doctor and he's because he wasn't
feeling good and he had a fever and the
doctor says yes I'm sorry he has measles
he said measles only measles you mean
you can't have something worse than that
to keep him from playing in sports it's
only measles which is absolutely the
truth they have demonized measles
demonized it and measles is a fever a
cough and a rash that for the vast
majority of children vast vast majority
of children it comes and goes in seven
to ten days and leaves behind a lifetime
of immunity which is very very important
in little girls because the the the real
measles strain antibody that comes from
actually having the real infection
caused and caused called measles when
they get older and they have children
and they are breastfeeding those types
of antibodies that come through their
breast milk from actually having the
real infection or of a higher quality
and higher duration to pass on to their
infant children which need to be
protected the most we know this from
studies in the 70s and the 80s of
looking at breast milk of children of
mothers who either actually had measles
or mothers who had a measles vaccine and
the quality and the longevity of those
antibodies are very different so that's
very important in third world countries
you know and so we have we've changed
the face of what we're doing not only by
trying to eliminate a virus that's a
Symbian that works together with our
bodies and to do good protective things
going forward but now we are being
detrimental to the next generation of
children from these vaccines what did
you say that what percentage was and
what's the worst thing that can happen
because sometimes we see that okay there
is a small percentage of something in
the net that from there people
capitalized to push the fear on you so
if there any infection you
name it any infection tuberculosis
hepatitis a Lessman leishmaniasis I mean
any sort of a parasite people can die
from any infection it's about the
terrain it's how healthy you are on the
inside out that when you get an
infection how well you can fight it off
keeping you preventing you by injecting
foreign matter into your body to weaken
your immune system makes you more
susceptible in fact there were several
good Canadian studies that show that
people that got flu shots increase their
risk of contracting the flu because that
weakened their immune system so I mean
people die from infections but the
numbers are extraordinarily small and if
people cheer injecting foreign matter
into healthy children to keep them from
catching a fever a coffin a rash so the
numbers are small and it's all about the
health of you health is an inside-out
phenomenon health does not come through
a needle we'll continue on with our
closest that we can come to a debate so
we're trying to ascertain the truth
fact-check based on science evidence
let's continue forward what I do
empathize with you and understand is
that the government telling people they
have to get vaccines right if you don't
do it they're not to be registered in
school that's a great thing to talk
about because in one sense you want to
have control over your body and what
treatments you partake in and what
illnesses you have that's your right to
choose and all of that but in the other
hand if you don't get immunized you can
harm other people and the reason why you
put people at risk is because not every
child can get the vaccine not every
child can be immunized some have a
genetic deficiency in in their immune
system where vaccines don't work on them
in French we have a coach of vaccine but
now I've heard recently in France it's
changing a little bit and we're thinking
about making it a law the international
community stands firmly with the US on
this one stop the international
community doesn't stand firmly with the
with the with the US on this they make
their own laws their own rules their own
vaccine schedules and the backup a
little bit about what he said about the
assumption is that every
person every child will be exposed to
these 17 different pathogens for which
we have a vaccine and every child will
be exposed and if you get exposed you
will get sick unequivocally and we know
that's not true I mean you can have a
classroom and say 30 children and two or
three of those children end up with
strep throat they end up with a real
slip honestly with a strep throat they
actually are culture positive for that
and every child in that room has been
exposed to that child coughing and
sneezing and all that stuff they've all
been exposed but only three out of the
30 gets sick so we know exposure is not
equivalent to illness you could be on an
airplane and somebody could be sick on
an airplane everybody's sucking in all
that recirculated air that's going on
but not everybody in that airplane gets
sick so exposure is not equal to illness
when you get sick you don't always get
worst case scenario you're gonna die
sick right some people get a light case
of the flu they got a little fever they
stay home a day or two you know some
people get in the pneumonia they get
walking pneumonia they can still go to
work so just even because you get sick
doesn't mean you're gonna get worst case
scenario you're gonna die sick unless
and then he makes the the analogy that
unless of course you're vaccinated for
then you won't get sick you won't spread
anything to anybody else and you're
gonna you're gonna protect other people
by getting vaccinated which explain it
which I've never fully understood their
argument about how if I get a vaccine
which actually sheds if I get a vaccine
how does that keep you from getting sick
if you smoke you take lots of drugs you
drink alcohol you're obese you've got
lots of other things how does me getting
a flu shot or any other vaccine keep you
from getting sick it's a myth that they
propagated and because they say it over
and over again like safe and effective
we make the assumption it's true so this
whole thing about the the the premise of
the vaccine industry is everybody will
be exposed when you get exposed you will
get sick when you get sick it will be
worst case scenario sick in fact you
might die unless of course you're
vaccinated then you won't get sick and
you won't die what's none of those
things are true none of them are true
when in my quest to try to get to the
truth to the bottom of things I was
to many different doctors going to some
people who would have more knowledge and
when we get down to really the meat and
potatoes and and we mention some of
these points these concerns sometimes
you get to one point that they're just
like well how can it be that all these
countries all these institutions who CDC
all them are in on this how can they
because they're the ones that are there
to protect us so how can they all be
ostensibly protect us we we we assume
that they are there to protect us are
they if UNICEF and the World Health
Organization and Gavi and all these
organizations pound these children in
third-world countries with all of these
vaccines some of which they don't even
need dr. Abbey's work has shown that
that in Ghana children that were
vaccinated with DPT vaccines were five
times more likely to die of other
infections you know are we really doing
humanity good things by trying to
vaccinate everybody in the world I don't
think so
and we assume that Gavi and UNICEF and
the World Health Organization they're
supposed to be there in their charter
there to protect us like the United
Nations do they are they doing things in
our best interest
somebody needs to pull you know they
pull back the curtain and see what's
really there so first of all they're
calling a vaccine preventable disease
deven table diseases as though you
couldn't you couldn't have prevent an
illness and infection by any other means
except vaccinating you couldn't just
wash your hands I mean there was a paper
that came out of Harvard in 2004 that
said you know we're always claiming that
vaccines are the savior of mankind the
vaccines have moved forward humanity
more than anything else except that's
not true this paper that came out in of
Harvard in 2004 said the most important
public health measure ever in the entire
planet all over the entire planet is
clean water clean water technologies
where you could wash your hands where
you could wash your food where you could
take a bath where you weren't where you
separated a hygiene where you went to
the bathroom from where you washed your
hands
I mean that is the most important public
hygiene is the most important thing that
has dropped the infection rates all over
the world that's how we view moved
humanity forward not by vaccinating but
by public health and public hygiene and
for sure with potable water and so you
know all of those so all of those things
that he was saying about you know that
all those children that are dying just
think about what's happening right now
with this covin 19 stuff that's
happening think about since this started
in March think about their predictive
models right I mean President Bush stood
on a stage with foutch II and Burks and
said if we do everything right
everything right we may limit the number
of deaths in the United States alone to
just two million people the week later
it was 8 maybe 200,000 people the week
after that was maybe 80,000 people and
then the week after that they started
fabricating death certificates and
putting covin 19 on anything that died
to confuse and confound the data that
will never know the truth they were
paying doctors more money to put them on
ventilators and to diagnose them with
Kovan 19 will never know the truth we
were they they've mixed up the data in
the testing they've taken nasal swabs
testing and blood serology testing and
mixed it all together we will never know
the truth
those are predictive models for stuff
which they're not head counts they're
predictive models so for him to say
UNICEF says the 20 million 20 people die
per second of fact really that's a model
it isn't something that's a
computer-generated model people aren't
walking out into villages and doing a
head count of the number of people who
died or didn't die of measles or
hepatitis A their predictive models and
as we know and we've seen it up close
and front-and-center through this whole
covent stuff predictive models are
almost always wrong so does he deserve
another facts check stamp another facts
second yes
read stamp all right they believe every
child should be vaccinated and in fact
there's such a shortage of back seats
throughout the world UNICEF says that
about one child dies
seconds from a disease preventable by
vaccine I heard today and I hear a lot
of times for my patients that they worry
that their kids are getting too many
vaccines all at once or they're getting
too many boosters in the first two years
of life and look the important things to
remember and what I really want to
reassure you is that that schedule is
there for a reason it's not based on a
personal whim it's not based on one
person's expert opinion it's based on
data quality studies that prove this is
the best way to deliver those vaccines
stop
he's absolutely I mean big it like ten
facts step fact check stamps on that Wow
first of all there has never ever been
any studies that have shown synergistic
toxicity like we talked about before
there's the only data that he's talking
about in terms of that schedule how they
test that schedule the only thing they
are looking for from the injection of
any vaccine any vaccine is does that
when I inject this foreign matter is the
result in antibody and by definition
that's what effective means we've been
led to believe that effective when they
say vaccines are safe and effective that
effective is a synonym for protection
it's not what what effective really
means is up I inject a foreign matter I
inject a DPT vaccine influenza hepatitis
B any of the vaccines when I inject it
if the result is I get an antibody then
that vaccine is effective because they
make the assumption that that antibody
it keeps you from getting sick which it
doesn't so when you look at that
schedule if you'll roll kids you can
roll back that video can you roll back
just just a hair you think right there
what look at all of those vaccines that
children get at two months of age they
are 60 days old on this planet they get
a hepatitis B vaccine that is an adult
sexually transmitted vaccine they get
rotavirus and they're living in a first
world country if they get sick with
rotavirus infection they get diarrhea
they can go to the hospital and be
rehydrated they get diphtheria tetanus
and pertussis pertussis vaccines have
been shown all over the place to not be
effective and that's why they're now
giving pertussis vaccines to pregnant
women to pregnant women trying with
loaded with aluminum to us
sensibly to try to protect an infant
from contracting pertussis here the
samatha influenza B if that was an
infection that was around quite commonly
and in them in the the nights in the
1980s and 90s and waffles influenza B is
a bacterial infection that during that
period of time was the most common cause
of ear infections and children under the
age of four
when they introduced the hip vaccine in
1991 and then they rolled it it actually
started using it more prevalently in
about 1994 they eliminated that bacteria
Haemophilus influenzae B from
circulation you don't see it hardly at
all anymore it's just like like they
they it's almost extinct but yet
children get four shots of that back of
that vaccine to protect them against a
bacteria that doesn't even that barely
exists anymore Prevnar PVC is prevalent
is a Prevnar vaccine they now use what's
called Prevnar 13 which means it has 13
different bacteria in that one shot so
getting just that one shot it's like
getting 13 vaccines all at the same time
and you get four doses of that and IPV
you know we're an IP V is polio so you
give they get four doses of polio even
though there's been no wild polio in the
Western Hemisphere Western Hemisphere
since 1994 there were about a hundred
cases of wild polio in the entire world
of seven point seven billion people and
only in worn torn areas and right now
because they still use the oral polio
vaccine in third-world countries
children are contracting paralysis from
the oral polio vaccine at a much higher
rate than they are from any wild virus
so the vaccines are causing more
paralysis than the virus and look at
they are getting all of those at the
same time at 60 days old they're getting
heavy
rotavirus DPT hip 13 strains of
pneumococcal vaccine and three strains
of polio injected in them
is it any wonder that children get sick
and die is it any wonder that the latest
article that came out by mark black soul
that was published by healthchoice that
shows that there are about 350 are there
about 700 deaths of children per week in
the United States about 700 children per
week die in the United States now some
of them are from accidents some of them
are from congenital problems like
congenital heart disease some of them
are from other types of what's called
inborn error of metabolism but about 350
children per week die in the America
alone under 1 year of age count up how
many vaccines children get by 1 year of
age they get 3 6 9 12 18 19 20 21
vaccines by 1 year of age and all of
those vaccines have a multiplicity of
antigens in them in fact I put together
a table a table that shows that by 1
year of age that they were children will
been injected with 95 foreign proteins
95 when are they going to be injects
posed to all of those pathogens at the
same time there is no science behind
this at all other than its convenience
it's that's doctor it's convenient back
in the up through 1985 there were only 3
vaccines there were DPT polio and MMR
that was it only 3 so before 19 before
1985 that's it there was only 3 it was
only 3 D PT or DTP polio and MMR and now
there are well they get multiple doses
of 17 by the time they're 18 years of
age so they get 6 a 6 of these vaccines
and if they only got one shot of each of
these it probably wouldn't be a big deal
but when you get shot at 2 months 4
months six months a year 15 months of
age and then you get a flu shot every
single year from 6 months of age going
forward and then you get your boosters
right before you go to school how can
any
buddy possibly believe that this is
necessary and that this is harmless
before we continue with the video I was
going to save some of these towards the
end but since you mentioned this shot
before 1985 it was interesting is it
true that after 1985 when this schedule
went up there was something called the
shielded liability around 1986 and then
all of a sudden it's coincidental then
when the shield he tell us about the
shield liability and then why all of a
sudden when the shield liability went
into effect the schedule just
skyrocketed well the night it was the
law was passed into effect was called
the National Vaccine injury the children
childhood Compensation Act was passed in
1986 signed into law by Reagan and they
and they he was forced to sign it
because the pharmaceutical industry he
said we're getting sued we're getting
sued every day by these kids who have
brain injury from this pertussis vaccine
we know it we've known it since the 60s
that that there's a subset of children
that every when they get up pertussis
vaccine as in the DPT vaccine they're
going to have brain injury oh yeah
autism right yeah oh we can't call it
autism it's just brain injury so they so
the pharmaceutical industry said if you
don't pass a lot of protect us we're
done we're out we're not making vaccines
anymore because we can't we can't pay
all that we can't we can't we can't
defend a crop against a product that we
know causes harm
we know these vaccines cause harm so you
need to pass a law Congress to protect
us from being sued by when our faulty
products get injected into children and
cause them to become injured for life or
die so they did they passed the die teen
eighty six Injury Compensation Act which
said any vaccine that is now on the
pediatric schedule there's no that
they're the but lock the vaccine
manufacturers cannot be sued so if your
child is injured or died they set up
something called through the federal
court of claims it's commonly referred
to as the vaccine court which means if
you've had an injury caused by vaccines
you have to get a lawyer and you have to
go through this process that's it can be
a two to three year process with no
guarantees that you're going to get
compensation it was originally set up to
be a non litigiousness
non-confrontational court like you have
an injury you submit your injury you get
a compensation it's not like that less
than 25 percent of people actually go
through the federal court of claims
actually get compensated and excuse me
it's a long dried out process and it's
very ugly and even now in to 2020 if
your child or you die from a vaccine
like immediately afterwards you have
anaphylactic dip and die the full
compensation for a death is only two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
that's it
4.2 billion dollars and they think that
is less than ten percent of the money
that should have been paid out for
injury compensation claims 4.2 billion
with a B I tell this over and over
against my patients especially when I'm
giving them a flu shot that they can't
get the flu from the flu shot in each
flu shot they estimate there's one
somewhere between one and two billion
viruses in a shot that's been kind of an
estimate that numbers kind of hard to
find but I found it I've seen it in
various places over the years they
attenuate that those viruses to let's
just use 1 billion to just keep the
numbers simple they they weaken them by
treating them with formaldehyde or to
phenoxyethanol formaldehydes a known
carcinogen or to phenoxyethanol which
can cause autoimmune diseases they
attenuate them or weaken them prove to
me prove it to me that 100% of those
viruses have been weakened so that when
you inject those that wider viruses into
the muscle of a human being at 98.6 that
those viruses will never reactivate and
cause illness because we know for a fact
from other things that viruses can
reactivate once they've been injected
into the body and they can recombine and
cause recombinants that can cause
illness you cannot prove it you can't
prove a negative so you can't prove that
those viruses are all 100%
ten you waited who can't prove that once
it's ejected into the body that they
don't revert to an activated stage which
there's science to show in other
vaccines that has happened that has
occurred you can't prove that in it that
it doesn't weaken your immune system to
make you more susceptible to what's
called an influenza-like illness which
influenza by strict definition is a is a
flu symptoms syndrome like you know body
aches fever chills cough all that
deep-seated stuff all that deep-seated
stuff only caused by influenza viruses
you can get a very similar syndrome
which causes which which has caused
influenza like illness because it can be
caused by other types of viruses and
bacterial influenza caused by influenza
viruses over the last 20 years of CDC
data which I crunched in on my own it
influenza viruses only cause illness of
all the illness that's out there in the
winter time about 15 percent of the time
it's like fourteen point six percent of
the time so if a flu shot is gonna work
at all it's gonna only keep you from
getting sick about fourteen percent of
the time and you can still get sick by
some other pathogen and yet there's
mercury and every one of the multi dose
flu shots and they they analyze them the
the amount of illness that's out there
and they'll say you know it's all this
is a very good match this year the
viruses in the and the vaccine only
match what's out in circulation fifteen
percent of the time so that means 15
percent of 15 percent is how effective
that vaccine is gonna be and I know
personally people one of them which is a
doctor who have taken the flu shot and
actually gotten the flu have gotten sick
so this is I mean it's pretty common
actually it's pretty common so what this
statement another one that he's saying
here that vaccine is made from inactive
virus that can't transmit transmitted
infection but a Harvard Medical School
but you have either because they don't
know the study that came out in 1986
that shows that when you get to a
virulent viruses together in a living
being it can cause a recombinant that
can caught that can be sick to two
generations that article that article
from 1986 was published in science
magazine
and they also don't understand about
what recombinant viruses mean and
reactivation of viruses mean so you know
all of this stuff is just it's
propaganda and it's like it's like a
religion like we talked about a few
minutes ago and if you say it over and
over and over and over again somehow
that makes it be true you have a lot a
lot of doctors you have a book called
medical heretic by a dr. Joseph
Mendelsohn
dr. niccole's Nicholas Gonzalez many
doctors who have come out because many
people make it seem like they're experts
on one side and this is just the laymen
you're an expert in this area 40,000
hours of research you have many this is
a dr. Joseph Mendelsohn he was one of
the leading pediatricians of 40s I think
almost over 30 years he was on the Board
of Advisors he spoke like what you're
speaking of people who really cared for
he meant they wanted to get the truth
out and they talked about many of the
same things that you're talking about
and they put everything they weren't
just parroting what people are saying
they actually did the research and they
committed to getting the truth out I
have a personal collection of over
12,000 articles that people out there
that are listening this you can go
access that do your own set for free
it's twelve thousand articles
hand-picked cherry picked because we
wanted that collection from only
peer-reviewed literature that shows
problems with vaccines and they can
research that by going to Tenpenny
research library comm Tenpenny research
library comm and you can you just have
to register for the to get access it's
free and you can just go in and you can
do your own research and look it just
fact check me go in fact check me so
they can fact check you we only have a
couple more minutes on this video we'll
get through it we're almost out of time
have you heard of these doctors these
brilliant doctors is dr. Joseph you have
you tell you've heard about the Nicholas
Gonzalez and he was a friend of yours
yeah he was also expecting us skeptic at
first wasn't he he was most physicians
are most physicians that you know I came
I told you you know I was the director
of an emergency a level two trauma
center for 12 years I gave up tetanus
shots to people never even never even
thought a thing about it do you
leave that if the common doctor if he
was just to evaluate do most just put
their brain on hold here and they just
go with parroting what they've been told
by the pharmaceutical company if many
would sit with you have many sat with
you like you went you went to a
scientific based convention was that
right you went to a canoe where there
were scientists there was doctors there
and they give you this evidence that's
why you had a change of heart change of
mind it's a really tough road to whole
for physicians these days you know I'm a
physician I still see patients two days
a week in my office and my clinic but
I'm an independent physician I'm not I
don't work for the Cleveland Clinic I
don't work for a University Hospital you
know and doctors have sold out they've
sold out they they talk like this young
physician here this little propagandist
out there right they they they sold out
they've sold their souls to the
pharmaceutical industry and they and
what they do for a living is they write
write words on a piece of paper and they
hand it out called a prescription all
day long you know that's what they do
and when they have sold out their
private practices to become an employee
of one of the large hospital systems
then the hospital systems push the
vaccines because it's the money driver
right we explained that you know goes to
the specialist the sub specialist and
then when you get a diagnosis then you
you get all these drugs and you've runt
you do x-rays and lab tests and fancy
tests like tilt table tests and all
these other things it's the economic
loss leader it's the driver for the
industry and because it's groupthink all
these people are like a pack of you know
L or they're like a pack of water
buffalos you ever watch some of those
those uh you know shows I'm like you
know safaris and stuff like that you
know water buffalos move like a pack
they all move together what happens when
one little water buffalo goes off and
strays over here by itself the lion eats
it so it's so much safer to stay part of
the pack and move together as a pack and
that's the way efficients are their pack
animals and they then they in like what
he says you know the you know the
consensus is so now we don't practice
individual medicine anymore on what's
important to the patient sitting in
front of us it's all by consensus and
algorithm driven and we all move as a
pack and if we all do it together we we
stick together then people can't say
anything against us we get that one
little water buffalo that comes over
here they
eaten by the lion was it like this did
these organizations the big ones when
you had the whole fight you had good
scientists good doctors people like
yourself were fighting just take it take
us back 20 30 years ago with the
nicotine industry so you had actually
people doctors smoking cigarettes and
they were providing their science but
there was a small group that was
fighting for humanity they were fighting
to get the truth out there
what happened were there also
institutions supporting the nicotine
industry like these big organizations oh
sure the Tibet you go back and read the
whole thing about the whole - the whole
tobacco industry it's the PlayBook of a
pharmaceutical industry or about the
asbestos industry that's an even better
one you know I mean it's live in a
pretty fascist society these days it's
run by and has for decades been run by
big industry big money you know in
government and big industry and big
money or go hand in hand
it's it's not easy being being the
alternative it's not easy being the
contrarian voice even though I think
what we've shared so far and I think
we're pretty close to the end of this
video that there's another side to this
story and when the consensus is only
spewing out propaganda and makes it seem
be pretty obvious that this nice
attractive young doctor is not done any
research on his own he really hasn't
because it's been my experience that
when people actually dig down into the
science and they actually start reading
things it's the rare person who says
yeah I read it all I've read both sides
and I'm gonna vaccinate anyways once
they really understand what is what is
coming through that needle and the tough
and the consequences of what's coming
through that needle together they're
like you know I've often said that
physicians if they really got their head
around this they would have two options
and only two one would be to slam the
book shut and say I'm I still believe in
vaccines I'm gonna trust that religion
I'm going forward and I'm gonna ignore
all the rest of it because that's how I
make my living I make a lot of money
doing this and I have to support my
family and have a roof over my head I'm
gonna ignore it and just go forward
which is what the lion's share the vast
majority of people do or they have to go
what have I done
by my arrogance and my stubbornness and
my unwillingness to look at what I could
be causing and I walk I open up my
electronic retina medical record or I
walked into my chart we can go asthma
allergies ad D autoimmune diseases
neurological problems SIDS Sid SIDS
encephalopathy seizure disorder I played
a role in that because I injected those
children with foreign matter and I had
no idea I didn't take my time because of
my arrogance my ego or I was lazy or
just busy and I just trusted that what I
was told was true dear God please
forgive me and find me a way out of this
so I can continue to make a living doing
something different because I can no
longer do this to my patients yes
options yeah this is important for the
community out there you mentioned God
for people who are God consciousness
Muslims are very God conscious we can't
follow our egos we can't fall into
cognitive dissidence like you talked
about if you really want to help
humanity I mean you gotta really get all
the evidence and you will be we believe
there's a paradise and there's a
Hellfire like and there's a day of
judgment you'll be held accountable so
this is something that you need to look
into and that's why we're bringing an
expert in this area to give us some of
these facts to fact-check and and we're
gonna be you're gonna be held
accountable I mean and this is a good
point you made if you fear God if you
love God you want to do right and you
you don't want to fall into the Hellfire
because of some of your stubbornness and
arrogance look at the whole thing from a
holistic maker is ignorance of knowing
these things gonna be defensible in
front of your maker because you didn't
take the time to go and investigate this
you don't have to put in 40,000 hours
like I have I've done all the work for
you
I created a library I have individual
courses we have a bootcamp course that
you can do the training you can come you
can get an individual one-on-one
consultation with me yes there's a fee
for that because I have to make a living
- right and so it's but what's gonna be
your defense when you stand in front of
your maker and you're in and he says to
you as you do unto the least of me you
do at least of these you do unto me if
you are injecting foreign matter into
children and causing them to become ill
and die
some to really think about so we got
another a minute 40 left on this we'll
try to get through this the reason why
people start thinking that is because
the season of when we give the flu shot
is the most common time of year that
people generally get colds and other
viruses just because two things happen
generally at the same time doesn't mean
one of those things stop stop that is
the biggest most non defensible lie that
they propagate right second only to safe
ineffective temporal association does
not prove causality that way they can
negate all of it anybody says I just got
a shot and now I have this a seizure
disorder my child died of sin its
overnight they just got those big
boatload of vaccines that we talked
about and then the next day the mom or
the dad goes in to check on the baby in
the crib and the baby's dead and they
take the baby to the ER and they said
they just got all six of those shots
yesterday does it have anything to do
with it oh no no no no no we don't know
what causes SIDS we don't know why
healthy babies just die we have no idea
but we know for sure had nothing to do
with those vaccines because temporal
association it happened at the same time
doesn't prove it caused everything it is
the way that they can wipe out vaccine
injury and wipe out any sort of thing by
that myth so you were the only you found
another fact check so I mean people love
their money so if you had a suitcase of
money and you and that was the only
person I went in the house nobody else
we can't connect the two right there was
no one no one else walked out of their
house or you were the only mechanic that
worked on their car and you put that
fluid in there and now the whole engine
blew it not just once but now this
happened multiple times thousands of
times but we still can't is this is this
what they say by causation correlation
that you can't I wrote a paper you could
find it out on the internet it's not a
paper was an article I wrote an article
called the Thanksgiving blue foot
syndrome and I put together this whole
kind of imaginary thing that the this
child had this swollen very painful blue
foot and they went to the doctor and the
doctor said yes it happens this time of
year we don't know what causes it we we
have no idea there's no treatment for it
it's going to be in the parents are
saying but they can't walk they've got
the swollen horribly painful blue foot
we have no idea what caused it there's
no treatment for it but the one thing we
know absolutely for sure is it is that
swollen blue foot was not caused by the
frozen turkey you dropped on it that's
so it's like we know for sure we don't
know what causes autism we don't know it
causes all these horrible things but we
know for sure it was not the vaccines
Wow so again like I said earlier we
started the show I'm not anti vaccine I
want something that's safe I want the
holistic picture I want to hear both
sides I want to be well informed like
any person with any intelligence before
they put their child or anything into
their body they want to make sure that
that thing is not going to harm the body
harmed their child so we're trying to
get all the facts and this is out of the
love that we're doing this so let's
continue on for those that were talking
about chemicals being found in our
vaccines it's true there are small my
new qualities of chemicals like for
example aluminum that stabilize the
vaccine or help prevent bacterial and
fungal growth stop first of all that's
not what aluminum does it's an adjuvant
it has nothing to prove
he's confusing aluminum and mercury so
he doesn't even have that fact straight
so there's a fact check it has nothing
to do with that and keep going because
this next part is really important well
okay all right stop yes we'll think
about that because there's a big
difference between ingesting aluminum
and injecting aluminum and how its
distributed and worked out of your body
he said he put 4.4 milligrams
well let me tell you something if a
child is completely vaccinated from
birth to 18 years of age and receives
every single dose of every single
vaccine they will have just shy of 12
thousand micrograms which is which is I
was twelve thousand micrograms which is
12 milligrams he has four point four
milligrams on his little slide there
they will have over 12 out almost 12
thousand micrograms
injected into their muscle which is the
picked up by the white blood cells it's
picked up by the white blood cells and
then transmitted to various parts of
their body including across the
blood-brain barrier into the brain
doctor sherry when you look at the if a
doctor takes out the insert and shows it
to his patient giving that's called
informed consent he needs to do that do
they do that and what would be on the
insert how many how many potential harms
is it is it five six seven side of phase
at hundreds what's actually on the
insert they don't show them the insert
in fact parents are never get to see the
insert a lot of times I've had parents
tell me that even when they ask for it
they're not they they don't give it to
him or they'll say this vaccine didn't
come with a package insert which is a
lie because the FDA requirements every
vial comes with the package insert in
the box that comes with it that is
that's what has to happen but they are
required to give them a something called
a vis Damon v as in Victor I SS and say
I'm a business statement which is a boil
down one pager which stands for vaccine
information sheet I think that's what
visits for the vaccine vaccine
information sheet they are required by
law to give every parent one of these
about each one of the vaccines and it's
a boiled down one pager that's all
fluffy and light and only tells you all
the wonderful probe's reads all the good
reasons why you should get this vaccine
and then down at the very bottom it will
say you know vaccines do cause harm
perhaps one in a million children become
harmed by a vaccine
well when children are getting you know
multiple doses they of these vaccines
over the course of time children get 35
vaccines by the time they start
kindergarten there was a new research
that came out probably in the last year
and a half that said the risk of
developing a reaction to a vaccine is
one in 33 kids get 35 vaccines by the
time they start kindergarten so it's
almost a hundred percent they're gonna
have a reaction from one of them and in
the reaction maybe just a fever and and
and a sore arm but it may be
high-pitched screaming that goes on for
days since these babies who have brain
inflammation that are going on that they
can't talk they can't tell you there's
almost 500 teenagers that have that
dead from the Gardasil vaccine almost
500 you know is since 2006 that they
died from that vaccine which is supposed
to keep them from developing cervical
cancer which it doesn't has never been
able to been proven to be efficacious in
that area at all I mean we could talk on
for hours and hours and hours about this
because there is another whole other
side of the story that isn't true back
to those of his statements first of all
they're required by law to give them
there was a study published in
Pediatrics a few years ago I'm gonna say
maybe 2010 ish frame that they actually
did a survey of pediatricians and how
many actually gave out that that
statement it was a really low percentage
I'm gonna say don't hold me to this
exact number but it's like was around
like 25 percent actually even only gave
that out and informed consent means that
you get full information like you get
everything that this doctor told you
that's on the pro vaccine side and and
everything that I've told you on the
wait a minute side right and then you as
a parent need to make a decision and
then informed consent it means that you
have a right to refuse to say you know I
don't want that hepatitis B stuff my
kids aren't aren't using drugs
I don't they are sexually active at 2
months of age I don't need that I don't
need this I don't need that or need that
I don't need any of those things that's
informed consent but now with these
vaccine mandates of saying that you have
to have your child vaccinated to go to
school in at least five of our states
and it's becoming harder and harder to
get exemptions and it's gonna be almost
impossible for adults to get exemptions
from this kovat vaccine that comes out
their informed consent no longer exists
you can be as informed about this as dr.
sherry temp any is you could put in
40,000 hours of time but if I don't have
a right to refuse
that's not informed consent that's
tyranny but the amount of aluminum
that's found in a vaccine is less than
the amount you find in baby formula or
breast milk think about that
just
with everything else in life vaccines do
carry some risks however most these
risks are fairly minor redness or
swelling of the injection site a mild
fever
nothing serious there are more serious
complications like anaphylaxis which is
a life-threatening allergic reaction but
it happens less than one in a million
cases and can be fully reversible by a
healthcare professional as a doctor my
job is to always weigh the benefits
versus the risk when doing anything
you're always forced to make decisions
and a lot of the time you have to make
decisions with incomplete information
but your job is to find the best
incomplete information and use that to
make a decision in this case for
vaccines we may learn something new
about vaccines in the coming years we
may learn that they weren't as good as
we thought or there's some other adverse
effects that we haven't thought of but
right now the information that's
available to you the quality information
shows that vaccines are good they have
higher benefit than risk and they
protect us so there's no doubt vaccinate
yourself and your kids I mean when
people this is one of the videos that
probably most a lot of people come
across has some of the highest views
he's a medical doctor and he's talking
with a lot of certainty and people now
look to him and they gravitate towards
his because he it comes off as this is
like divine it's coming down like it's
Scripture it's from God this is like
there's no question about this like it's
been decided consensus of the medical
community and anyone who goes out of
that they're crazy they're the person
that needs to go get fact checked and
have their head examined I mean and he
concluded that this is pretty much the
risk what do you say about the the
greater good like okay there are there
are some potential harm side effects but
the the greater benefit that's what
we're looking at public health needs to
be more than a high vaccination rate and
a low infection rate in a very short
list of pathogens there's seventeen what
about the trillions of bacteria and
viruses that we carry around with us
every day what about the all of the
other VAX all of the other types of
pathogens that I actually do cause
infections that we don't have vaccines
for like MRSA like you know group of
flesh-eating ecoli like some of the
bacteria bacteria and parasites that we
see in third
countries you know the only ones that we
get are knickers in a knot about our
ones that we have a vaccine for so the
and when we look at we've got the
sickest generation of children ever in
the history of the planet and what is
the one commonality they're high
vaccination rates by a whole bunch of
vaccines that are given to kids by the
time they're one year of age is that
true
this is another thing that is concerning
that after you had 1985 was it 1 in
10,000 what was the number as before the
shield of liability that you cannot
actually sue the vaccine company
directly so you had you mentioned before
1985 it was like three of these shots
and it was like 1 in 10,000 that was
approximately that was the estimate that
was like 1 in 10,000 children had autism
now depending on where you are it's like
1 in 34 it's actually 1 in 34 in certain
areas in New Jersey and there and and 1
in 43 I believe in certain areas of
Florida but but someone will say we
weren't able to diagnose it as good
that's why and I always use that it's
like if doctors didn't recognize
children that couldn't communicate we're
talking hand flapping banging their
heads on the floor as a pathology before
then they should they should have their
license yanked mm-hmm okay well let me
just get through these a few more
questions
dr. Tenpenny herd immunity so the reason
behind you having okay if you have your
decision you feel like you need to put
this in your child and you but now some
other people who they feel like okay
it's my god-given right to protect my
body and I find that this there's no
science behind it is there a the gold
standard of medicine is the double-blind
placebo is there a double-blind placebo
in this that once are you kidding me
they had a half of a study that they did
with Gardasil that they used some saline
but usually even like in the Gardasil
vaccine what they used as a placebo was
a shot of aluminum and there's lots of
aluminum in the Gardasil so what the
side effects were the same and now they
don't call them classy bows anymore they
call them comparators because as of 2016
the new
rules for research are is that if you
have a to groups like when you're
bringing a new vaccine to market you got
the new vaccine over here let's say
there's a hundred people and there's a
hundred people in this group and I'm
just using these numbers just to make it
simple right so you put the new vaccine
in this group you have to give something
of equal benefit to the control group
because it's it's it's a it's considered
unethical to give them a true placebo so
when you're looking at safety and you're
looking at side-effects what you're
doing is you're looking at the
side-effects of the new vaccine compared
to the side-effects of another vaccine
and if they seem to be the same then
they can say the side effects of the new
vaccine is equal to the placebo which
they now call equal to the comparator so
yes so there's so double-blind
placebo-controlled trials have have not
been done since the polio vaccine when
they use the when they use the tetanus
shot and the polio vaccine just look for
safety I mean it's not it's not held to
the same standard at all in fact there
was a World Health Organization meeting
held in Geneva it was in December of
2019 where all of the big shots the big
Wiggy wigs were sitting around talking
about you know all of these these things
and one of the researchers there you can
find that on the big trees high-wire
site the entire the entire conference
one of the women at the conference said
yeah you know those those anti VAX we
really don't have good science
we really don't and one of the people
there said well the studies the the
cohorts are small so the groups that we
do the testing on are small we don't
follow them for very long we follow it
from anywhere from four to 14 days
because we follow them longer we know
that some of those kids are going to get
sick and then we have to stop the trip
the trial and then figure out if it was
the vaccine or not we we know that we
don't really use a placebo so maybe we
should start doing like some real
science now when I heard that I mean I'm
sitting here at my computer I mean my
head almost my jaw like dropped the
table it's like we've been used that
we've been injecting foreign matter into
children for 200 years we've been using
an adjuvant like aluminum you know ASO 3
ASO 4 we've been
using lots of mercury we have all of
these chemicals we use cells from
aborted fetuses we use cow blood and in
gelatin from pigs we have all of this
stuff that we've been injecting into
children for all of these years and you
guys are just now coming clean and
saying we don't have good science on
this that's what I'm for I'm for good
science so like I said earlier that I I
want is there something wrong why should
you slander attack you know malign
someone or people who are saying we want
good science and we want the double with
that a study between children who are
with the shots those who are not to
vaccinate unvaccinated is there a study
like that so we got confirmed that
there's no double-blind placebo that
means that how does that work you give
someone a sugar pill one not not you
give one to vex one they don't and then
they actually compare this is like the
gold standard of medicine many doctors
thinks there is but so it's a fact it's
not so they should jump on and also push
for that right because that would help
actually and give us real science that's
the gold standard of science and there
are some so that's right and there are
some small studies that have come out by
surveys and things that have looked you
know what you're referring to is this
said the vaccinated versus unvaccinated
study you know we could have look at the
health of vaccinated kids fully
vaccinated kids versus the health of
completely unvaccinated kids there are
some small studies that have come out
there I think there's two or three that
show that the incidence of of allergies
and ADHD is exponentially higher in the
vaccinated kids versus the unvaccinated
kids but herein lies the rub now they're
starting to vaccinate pregnant women I
mean we could never even give pregnant
women an antihistamine or anything
before because you know we didn't want
to have any impact on the fetus but now
we're giving pregnant women pertussis
vaccines and flu shots that can cross
the blood can cross the placenta and
adversely affect that rapidly developing
and growing fetus so when that baby's
born even if the parents decide to not
vaccinate if the mom had vaccines while
she was pregnant that child really isn't
completely unvaccinated it's been
exposed to those vaccine antigens so we
confirmed there's no
gold-standard there we also confirmed so
there is some stud there's a small this
is independent studies with the vaccine
unvaccinated and it showed that in these
studies that there was high level of
what asthma and what else ADHD it's
there so people can check this up we're
like I'm PubMed or where can they go and
look for these things are they on their
website one of them came out of Germany
one of them was done by Generation
Rescue that who actually did it and then
it sticks in my mind that there was a
third one relatively recently done and
there's been some you know surveys and
things that have been done but all you
have to do is look around let me talk to
parents of unvaccinated kids and say how
many days to school to your kids miss a
year like none or hardly any how many
chronic daily prescription medications
are your kids on none you know and then
talk to parents whose kids are fully
vaccinated your kids are sicker their
kids are sick all the time they always
have ear infections sinus infections
they're cranky they don't learn as well
in school they're on daily prescription
medications you know I always remember
this talk that I gave years ago at the
Wisconsin Chiropractic Association
meeting and this gentleman this one of
the physicians the chiropractors came up
to me and he said you could do a study
just on my family he said I have six
children and I think three oldest
children are completely vaccinated and
my three youngest children are
completely unvaccinated same genetics
same laundry detergent same food same
animals in the house I mean two
completely different subsets he said my
older children are more combative they
don't do as well in school they're not
as socialized there's they have a lot of
stillness that seems like they catch
every virus that comes through my
younger three kids are super bright
they're easy to get along with they
never get sick even when their siblings
are sick they never get sick it's like
two completely different families living
in my house and the one big distinction
is I mean the only distinction is that
the three older ones were completely
vaccinated and the three younger ones
were completely unvaccinated Wow
so just a few more questions most of
them you addressed when we were going
over the reaction to this video herd
immunity so they say the people say now
okay
it's your right okay if you want to put
that anybody other ones say look I've
done my research I'm more for science
you actually it seems like you're more
anti science because you know there's no
gold standard there's no independent
safety testing etc etc they've confirmed
they've done the research
but now the person says no we need to
develop herd immunity so now you're
gonna get us sick if you don't so what
is this herd immunity and this argument
for it well it's kind of a long answer
the the bottom line is is that herd
immunity was meant to be applied against
a group of a population of people who
had the real infection the vaccine
industry co-opted that they stole it and
applied it against the vet and applied
it to vaccines saying that you have to
have a 95 percent or better vaccination
rate to stop transmission or we're going
to have outbreaks and if you have four
or five or ten or 50 kids that have an
outbreak of pertussis why do we get so
hysterical about that and have to go and
revaccinated e I mean we have we've
become the fears of the germ I mean this
sort of like everything that's going on
right now with this Kovan stuff you know
with the masks and the social distancing
and the gloves and you know what makes
us think that the only way that we're
going to come in contact with a with a
virus or a bacteria is through a human
contact you know isn't it floating
through the air isn't it like you know
when you pet your dog or your cat I mean
we have to understand we have to get
back to the fact that God gave us an
amazing immune system you know when
children were born you know you don't
look down at your bait you know can you
just imagine you know God standing over
your shoulder and looking down and going
oh I made a horrible mistake
I forgot the immune system please hurry
vaccinate we were born whole and
complete and intact and that we were
given everything that we needed to have
to live on this planet symbiotically
with viruses and bacteria and to be able
to protect ourselves from the inside out
when we do good things for our bodies
when we skip adequate sleep when we wash
our hands when we eat good food when we
drink good water when we pray when we
get involved you know because prayer
does have really good things in terms of
your immune system they've actually done
Studies on those things
so when you have those things from the
health is from the inside out it does
not come through a needle the I think
anyone who doesn't know much on this
topic there's a great documentary and
before even if you're I really recommend
doctors to watch this can you tell us
just in brief who was the scientist is
it's called the documentary is called
vast and there was a CDC scientists who
actually came out and said that we
manipulated the data we changed things
you know you you know about this
obviously can you tell us a little bit
about this and why this is important why
people should watch it was a CDC
researcher and they were crunching the
data on the MMR vaccines and what they
found was that the mumps fraction of the
MMR vaccine was was causing an
accelerated incidence of autism yes
autism primarily in black boys and they
knew this and they've known it for years
and they shredded the data they scrubbed
the the the Internet of all of the data
they never really published it there his
fellow researchers lied to Congress lied
to Congress that there was no
correlation and yet he had a it was a
man of consciousness and eventually he
said I can't keep this in anymore I'm
seeing what's happening in the black
population particularly to black boys
and they're being decimated I have to
tell you what our research was and he's
a CDC whistleblower and that's what the
entire movie is about is showing that
the CDC whistleblower and the CDC has
held this data all these years so if you
think that the CDC the NIH the World
Health Organization Gavi UNICEF they're
doing good things for Humanity pull back
the curtain and do a little research
it's all propaganda you know it's like
they read the book probably 1984 right
1984 if you haven't read it I encourage
everybody to read it if you have you did
read it a long time ago yep and it's
about the you know what we're
experiencing now is the Ministry of
Truth which means that the only truth is
what comes from government and
government makes it up and becomes
propaganda and if you go against the
Ministry of Truth you end up dead and
in one way or another either either
physically dead or metaphorically dead
in terms of ostracized and called names
and mudslinging and character
assassination and all of those things
I'm not afraid of that I mean I'm doing
this for the betterment of humanity I'm
trying to say every time a parent says
to me it was because I heard your video
or your I watched your video I heard
your interview on such-and-such 15 years
ago I heard you speak and I looked into
what you had to say and it's because of
you and what you said and I did my own
research that my kids are healthy
healthy healthy and completely
unvaccinated I always just say a little
prayer of thanks and say you know what
another child was just snatched from the
jaws of the pharmaceutical industry and
being a customer of life remember the
word pharmaceutical Pharma comes from
the word pharmakeia which is a Greek
word that means sorcerer or witchcraft
so it's a pharmakeia is pharmacy the
pharmaceutical industry that's the base
word of that is from the Greek which
means sorcerer or witchcraft it becomes
that belief system that we believe in
vaccines rather than looking at it as a
product that can be injected into a
human body and caused great harm really
exciting to have you on the program we
covered a lot and God willing we can
continue on in a part - thank you so
much and people where can people go to
look at some to get more information you
mentioned you you've actually put some
of the research some of the science
that's out there that you've collected
and what website well if you go to the
primary website that people can go to
his courses for mastery courses the
number for mastery comm because we have
a lot of internet properties because we
have a lot of different course offerings
you can find the library there our
bootcamp vaccine you you can find our
social media platforms you can find out
about me you know doctor temp any comm
you want to do a little bit more
research on this crazy person what is
she really all about you can find all of
that if you go to courses the number for
mastery comm mmm thank you God bless you
god bless you thank you so much same to
you
peace thank you
and that was dr. sherry with over 40,000
hours on the topic getting into the
science and really I think it's
important that you walks watch this
documentary VAX like I said I'm not anti
vaccine but I want to make sure that I
get all of the information we as Muslims
we're not blind followers of anything
except what led us to the Quran and the
Sunnah what led us to Islam is that it
was evidence-based it was evidence-based
that we looked at the evidence that we
confirmed through all of the things that
are mentioned in there that there's no
way that this could have come from
anyone other than the Creator that
happens on earth and anyone who's humble
and sincere and looks at the evidence
they'll come to the conclusion - and
then we see also that if we've been lied
if there is also another side to this
that we should not just blindly go into
cognitive dissidence we should look at
all the facts look at what these people
these doctors scientists who are
independent outside of the mainstream
because what happens when you go outside
the mainstream you lose your grants what
happens if you don't tow the line what
happens you lose your job you lose your
position you can lose it all but what
happens when someone goes and speaks the
truth they get maligned they get
attacked
we know how Islam gets attacked how the
media is able to go ahead and push out
the misinformation and get people scared
of Muslims when people do the research
they see that there is more chance of
you getting killed by your furniture
then some suppose of Muslim terrorists
and then when you look at really what
Islam is all about promoting peace
justice mercy connection with your
Creator the one and only the one that
Jesus worship Moses Abraham the last if
I don't mention your problem I'm at
peace and blessings be upon them all you
see that Islam is a way that brings
peace and contentment to the heart
connects people with my Creator it
caused me to be morally upright to do
good deeds to be a good human being and
then on and on I'm just making this
parallel this correlation now when
someone investigates looks into it
versus someone who doesn't so when
someone doesn't look into the deen into
Islam what happens they're scared of it
but when someone really gets to know
Islam and Muslims then
that fear is eradicated there's
potential power there but you have to
look into it now make that contrast here
when you just blindly follow then you
have a whole group of scientists doctors
experts in this field who are coming out
and telling us the opposite of what
we've been told anybody with some
scruples intelligent he wants to know
hold on you're not gonna decide for me
let me look at the evidence just like
you and you can't use this excuse now oh
I just go to the to the experts hold
down we're going we brought on an expert
now there's two suppose suppose of
experts you don't put your brain on hold
when it comes to the to the Dean to the
son now you look at what both scholars
have to say you look at the evidence
who's bringing the solid evidence from
the Quran and the Sunnah what about here
who's who's really bringing the evidence
and then when you find out that
something's fabricated weak you go to
the stronger position to stronger side
but not always is the stronger side with
the mainstream is it now we have
countless examples the whole world has
been brainwashed that Muslims are
terrorists they're Muslims that Islam is
evil look at that is there evidence
behind it it's a clear-out lie and
people exaggerate from a small fringe
group of evil people misguided people
who will do something some hideous evil
act and then the media pushes out there
and uses them examples of ague of one
point almost 2 billion Muslims out there
is that fair is that right no but we can
see the media manipulation look how the
media pushed out that there was weapons
of mass destruction and they they
convinced the whole world to go and
pillage and you had rape and you had how
many innocent human beings were killed
in these war on terror and on weapons of
mass destruction and then it came out
later that it was a lie look at that
but if you follow the mainstream what
would happen look just look these are
just a couple examples but there are far
more and many couldn't be here that we
also there's more to it so I really
advise my brothers and sisters in the
Dean and in humanity to take another
look a closer look to pray to the
creator of the heavens and earth God
Almighty never who say Allah to guide us
and then really look at the evidence
good place to start look at this
documentary Baxter I really recommend
everybody to watch it watch
what do you have to lose especially the
scholars in the Dean especially those
who the people look to because we've
been pointing to experts but there's a
whole nother group of experts so now we
have to go back to the drawing more
drawing board maybe and look reevaluate
things because if now we're helping
potentially we're gonna be as she was
saying well hey how are you gonna stand
in front of your maker
how if you've helped to contribute to
potentially harming harming humanity and
these children out there we want to be
safe so we should look at everything
from a holistic perspective look at all
the evidence look to the other side of
scientists and doctors and and if we're
sincere and we want to get to the truth
God Almighty Allah will guide us to that
truth but we can't just close our eyes
and blindly follow the mainstream
because how many times has the
mainstream been wrong so may God
Almighty Allah help us to see truth is
truth falsehood is falsehood and to be
able to follow that truth and help to
make us a benefit for humanity this is
out of the love that we're doing this
again we are pro science we are we want
to go where the evidence leads us
towards the correct science not things
that been manipulated or fabricated we
want to go towards the truth and true
science and I hope that this video this
program has been to some benefit and
again if there's anybody out there who
would like to challenge this challenge
the doctor contact us let's have a
debate about it let's talk about it and
we'll see you next time here inshallah
God willing I'm DS show until then peace
be with you
[Music]
you